respond Richardson has the latest from
the State Department the American
Secretary of State and the North Korean
vice chairman there in New York the
highest level official North Korean
visit to the United States in 18 years
the conversation is going to be focused
on denuclearization of the peninsula
that's what these ongoing conversations
taking place now will be centered on as
well as this summit that would take
place in Singapore the administration
says secretary Pompeo will join vice
chairman kim yeongcheol for dinner
tonight tomorrow a day of meetings to
set up a summit between president Trump
and Kim jong-un the secretary and kim
yeongcheol have met twice before when
Pompeo traveled to Pyongyang is CIA
director and then later is Secretary of
State they've had obviously very deep
conversations where they've talked about
a lot of detail about what the United
States expectations are kim yeongcheol
is immersed in North Korea's recent
diplomacy joining kim jeong-hoon for
meetings with the presidents of China
and South Korea he spent several years
leading North Korea's Intelligence
Service and is still under US sanctions
he's suspected to have been involved in
North Korea's nuclear program the
sinking of a South Korean ship in 2010
and even the hack of Sony in 2014 the
State Department says secretary Pompeo
spoke over the weekend with foreign
ministers from South Korea and Singapore
and he's scheduled to meet next week
with the Japanese prime minister in
Washington North Korea is also planning
with its allies ahead of the June 12th
summit in Singapore
Russian Foreign Minister Sergey Lavrov
is scheduled to travel to North Korea
this week Kim jong-un has met twice in
recent weeks with Chinese President Xi
Jingping as the Trump administration's
relationship with China is showing
renewed strain Secretary of Defense
James Madison's the US will continue
sailing through disputed international
waters China considers its territory
there's a very very steady drumbeat of
freedom of navigation
operations you'll notice there's only
one country that seems to take active
steps to rebuff them or state their
resentment of them the trouble
administration also says it is moving
forward with tariffs on Chinese imports
and restrictions on Chinese investments
to that China's foreign ministry has
responded that it does not want a trade
war but that it's not afraid of fighting
warning